[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
tomorrow morning as they arrive hot off
the press and it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the Edison
chief of the newspaper group National
world cities Nancy Fielder we're also
joined by the former conservative MP and
royal advisor Mary McLeod very good
evening to you both will be with you
just shortly first though
um we're going to have a look at what's
on those front pages now starting with
the financial times it has word of
thousands of redundancies at Twitter as
its new owner Elon Musk warns of a
massive loss in revenue for the social
media platform on the same story The
Daily Stars Infamous head of lettuce is
making return this time with Mr musk as
its Target suggesting his tenure Twitter
could be even shorter than Liz truss's
Premiership in a wide-ranging interview
with the times tomorrow morning where
she sent out pledges to regain the
Public's trust after mistrust's brief
stint with number 10 but warns that the
state cannot fix everyone's problems and
the express warns that Mr sunak that its
readers will not vote Tori again if he
ditches the long-standing pledge to
maintain a triple lock on pensions
possible changes to tax rates on
pensions is the main concern as well for
the Telegraph and the guardian tomorrow
quotes the UN Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez insisting that rich countries
must do more do a deal with poorer
counterparts at the forthcoming cop 27
climate Summit or else in his words we
will be doomed
a Cyber attack on the NHS three months
ago has left patients records and by
extension their care in a state of chaos
as according to the eye newspaper and
onto the mirror now it hears that the
former Health secretary Matt Hancock
isn't only taking part in I'm a
celebrity he's also skipped the
Conservative Party Conference to appear
in Channel 4 celebrity SAS who dares
wins to be which is yet to be shown
the email carries new claims surrounding
The Disappearance of Lord Lucan in the
1970s and the sun reports that the
veteran actress Patsy Kensit will soon
join the cast of EastEnders
quick reminder as well for you that by
scanning the there you are the QR code
you'll see on the screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch with us
so we are joined tonight by Nancy
Fielder and Marion McLeod let's chat to
them now ladies thank you so much for uh
staying up late on a Friday night to
talk to us and let's start off with the
um Times newspaper a wide-ranging they
say that the first major sit-down
interview with our new prime minister
his he's telling us that he's going to
regain the Public's trust and he can't
fix all of our problems Nancy what do
you make of it
well I mean I think my first reaction
has to be they've certainly created a
lot of our problems so they should at
least step up and fix the ones that they
can it is a very in-depth interview
um it is quite interesting to sort of
see a side of him we haven't seen for
quite a while obviously there was the
leadership campaign when it was all
about attacking each other now is that I
mean it's a very very interesting read
people are interested in the latest
prime minister but there's nothing
reassuring in there he's trying to be
calm he's trying to look like this is
the party and the leader that the
country needs but there is no promise to
actually help people he says they'll do
what he can but actually there is a lot
that can be done that isn't been done
and he's not really tackling anything
head-on so well it's a nice read it
doesn't really reassure me at all and I
don't think it will reassure many of the
biggest labor voters who voted for Boris
Johnson at last election yeah he goes on
to say that he he recognizes the anxiety
that millions of people have about
mortgage repayments and he's going to do
everything he can to get a grip but he's
saying that there's a limit to
government intervention Mary
yes and I think what is also just trying
to be is very realistic in this and
really showing that this is
unprecedented times and therefore
there's some big issues right now and
it's not even a month ahead as right now
and it's the I think the period that
this will last is for some time and
therefore he can't be hugely reassuring
because that will come in the things
that he delivers as part of the budget
statement and then when he delivers the
those things alongside the the
chancellor so I mean what he has said is
that he's promised to be fair and
compassionate and which I hope he will
be and but we will find that out in the
the weeks ahead when we hear the
statements in in Parliament and but you
know he's very clearly sort of saying
um I'm being honest I'm being realistic
about the size of the scale of the a
challenge that we have and but there's
this urgent need naturally to restore
economic stability and but it will take
it won't happen overnight it's going to
take time and therefore it will be very
difficult and we can think back to the
times where we've had austerity and
previous you know economic crisis where
um people have really suffered and my
concern is that yes you know we've seen
inflation and the impact on interest
rates and and I just worry that yes it
affects mortgages but the debt that
people are going to potentially get into
and not been able to deal with and that
I think this will affect far more people
than is even anticipated
um and just digging a bit further into
the article he also talks about his
defending claims apparently by swella
bravaman or braveman I should say the
Home Secretary that uh Britain was
facing an invasion of illegal immigrants
and pledged to cut overall levels of
migrain I mean the government's had a
difficult week haven't they to say the
least on the issue of Asylum Seekers
what did you make of his uh decision
there to defend his Home Secretary Nancy
I don't think he's got much Choice he
made the rather silly decision
um to give her the job and it is pretty
indefensible but here we are again with
the Prime Minister defending somebody
who quite frankly shouldn't be in the
job and it's a shame I mean we all need
a good prime minister whatever your
politics right now this country really
really needs some good strong leadership
and he's distracted everybody is
distracted by somebody who's not very
clear it shouldn't be in the job and who
is using words that shouldn't be used
inflammatory words against people and
who we should be helping and it is it's
a massive massive issue there is no easy
answer but it's been dealt with really
really badly and and everybody everybody
knows we just need to really focus on
how we help immigrants but actually
we've got massive problems here too so
the sort of fighting over who is right
in the job is really causing more
problems then we just need Solutions
yeah I could imagine there's a nice bit
of color there saying that he hadn't
expected to become Prime Minister
because of course he lost the leadership
campaign of a summer and he had moved on
so there you go let's move on to some
other stories now and Mary and onto the
front page The Daily Telegraph pensions
targeted in stealth tax rate of course
we're going to find out aren't we in a
couple of weeks what they've got up
their sleeve in terms of um tax hikes
for all of us what are the telegraphs
saying
yes and I think it's
um a you know it'll be a worrying story
for lots of pensioners and that's I
think what's so disturbing about some of
the the Press at the moment there's just
so much sort of negativity out there I
mean it's real so it should be on there
but it's just
um it's very depressing read for for
most people and this of course on the
pensioners front as well is that you
know they will really if they sort of
rule back on some of the promises that
were made to pensioners and then that
will cause huge problems down the line
and for for the government so something
that they will be taking very seriously
but we won't know of course until that
budget statement comes out and we we
hear more about it but they will
certainly I mean pensioners are known to
to say what they think and they will
um not let this drop in terms of what
um they would have expected to get the
support and backing um of the government
especially these difficult times and and
you know and we also you know we just uh
you know we're coming into winter it's
going to be a moment where
um the more vulnerable oral was you know
the more elderly as well and therefore
you know we should be backing them as
much as possible so yeah and an
interesting woman and again the
government will be judged on how they
deal with it Nancy what do you think is
the government right to look again at
the pension triple lock an area that has
been kind of seen as the holy grail for
many governments
I think the government's got to look at
everything right now I think we really
really need to find ways to save money
but actually it feels like we've never
come out of austerity I don't feel it's
ever we've ever ever had a time where
there's been a good time for public
services the NHS is crippled we'll talk
about transport later no doubt but the
trains and buses are awful and actually
our pensioners are sat there really
really worried everybody is worried
about what is coming up this winter we
every year in cities like minus cities
like Sheffield there are pensioners who
die because they don't put their heating
on because they can't afford it imagine
what that is going to be like this
winter because it's going to be much
much worse than ever so they have got to
look at everything but they're doing
flip-flopping u-turning everywhere so
some of you are showing us as to what
they're actually going to do and let us
at least try and deal with it will be
good yeah interesting to move on to the
the express now because they're taking
the same story but with a very different
stance of course we know the Daily
Express is always a been a champion but
for pensioners and and that you can
certainly sell that with its headline
ditch to Triple lock and we won't vote
Tori again they're saying Mary
yes that's really but I was you know
mentioning earlier is that they
absolutely will make it very clear about
how they feel about this issue I mean
they always felt the triple lock
um was a promise that was given them and
were were absolutely
um believed that that therefore would be
would be delivered so therefore they
they're you know this is about watching
this space in terms of what will be in
that budget I mean what's interesting
about some of the stories coming out is
that it's almost I think the government
trying to manage the markets in terms of
what
um might be in that
um and also help I guess so Republic
opinion feel
um what there aren't so many surprises
but you know it's these are going to be
a completely
um you know agree with Nancy there that
this will be you know an awful winter
for a lot of people and it's not going
to end at winter it's going to go on
um and there's just so much geopolitical
uncertainty there is so much disruption
out there everywhere you look
um and therefore this is going to be to
be to be really tough and I think what I
guess the Prime Minister has tried to do
is say look up we're I'm hearing I'm
listening we will try and be fair and
help those most in need so I really hope
he does do that okay on to uh the
guardian now we will be doomed without a
climate pact says the UN chief of course
is head of cop27 that takes place in
Egypt this weekend Nancy um are you
hopeful I mean we've just talked about
how Bleak the Outlook it is for the UK
but also for many other countries around
the world I mean are you hopeful that
countries will put their their current
problems aside for a bit look at a
long-term future try and save the planet
do you have any hope
no I wish I could say that I don't want
to be all doom and gloom but I mean it
doesn't seem a long time ago since that
since we were in Glasgow and everyone
was making the promises and everyone was
saying oh the next year is crucial and
here we are a year later in a blink of
an eye all sorts of things have happened
and actually what has progressed now
small things may have progressed but the
whole focus of this seems to be on
making people commit and actually take
action rather than just giving us words
and it's quite a simple message actually
in in this article in everything we're
hearing in the build up to cop this
weekend it's the the rich countries like
ours seems funny in the context of many
conversations but we are a rich country
um is causing huge problems for
countries like India countries like
Somalia this is not something in the
future this is something that's
happening now and I'm not hopeful that
that with that bothered we're not we're
bothered in terms of words but their
actions were just not getting so I feel
this is repetition and something
dressing has got to be done Mary you any
more hopeful because I'm I'm probably
it's slightly more positive than that
just because I think that
um cop 26 you know we're really short in
glass school there that we did feel this
was our that this is really important it
was really good to see the event that
the king led
um with politicians and a Business
Leaders as well
um that just to show that actually this
is a really really important issue and
that more needs to be done and there
will be tensions around that sort of
equity and fairness within who has to
pay out more because you know the U.S
China Russia and the EU emit 63 of the
carbon pollution in the atmosphere while
10 of the most sort of climate
vulnerable nations are collectively
responsible for about one percent so you
know the the themes will talk around the
sort of mitigation the adaptation
finance and and collaboration but I
always come back to this collaboration
piece
um and that's why I'm glad also the
prime minister is attending because even
although there are you know three other
membership cabinet going I still think
it's important we have to show
leadership
um on this
um and we did a such a good job at Club
26 I really want us to keep flying the
flag and bearing the mantle for this and
showing that we absolutely need to do
this for the future
um of the for the world and and and it's
the future of humanity we're going to go
to our last two stories it's not every
day that you see the financial times and
the daily Stars sharing a front page in
terms of choosing the same story to lead
with that they have for tomorrow uh the
Ft weekend talking about of course those
big job cuts at Twitter with Elon Musk
in charge and the Daily Star have found
someone who's resurrected the limp
letters if you remember that one
wondering whether the letters is going
to outlive Elon Musk as the owner of um
of Twitter taking a lighter note um
Nancy what do you make of this story and
the way that they're going about these
Mass job cuts
it's pretty horrendous isn't it I mean I
think everybody must be questioning
whether they stick by Twitter whether
they're using it or whether they
advertise on it I mean anybody who sucks
people by email anybody sort of
instantly we're wearing all sorts of
stories people are having their laptops
wiped to having all their access to
their emails just instantly gone and
they haven't done anything wrong have
they this is not people have been
searched for misbehaving this is because
um the richest man in the world has
taken over and people don't always like
his stunts on things so the platform it
instantly took a hit and he says he
needs to strengthen it up I mean the
letters is actually a Twitter executive
sort of saying will he be sacked by Elon
before the lettuce wilts and disappears
as did the last prime minister I mean
it's good it's joking about it was a bit
absolutely awful in the circumstances
which we've just been discussing where
people are struggling for the mortgages
anyway these are hundreds if not
thousands of jobs and people just thrown
out into the cold uh Mary briefly if you
don't mind is this a sign of the time
times
well possibly but I mean I think
certainly in in this case
um partly I'm not surprised and
certainly if he's done anything to to
breach employment laws he'll be held to
account for that but
um he sounds like he might be getting
rid of about half the staff and he's
looking at other revenue streams for
Twitter and I've been following him on
Twitter saying about the eight pie
dollars per month to to be accredited on
Twitter so he he is an innovator he's
highly intelligent
um he does things at a huge speed so
there's partly I'm not surprised at some
of this and but the human element and as
someone who does work and leadership in
HR you know it's absolutely important
well these devastating times when people
have uncertainty and lose their job that
you support them through that process
switch and we will see whether he does
or not but certainly there's already I
think a class action lawsuit from some
of the Twitter employees going to him so
we'll find very soon we